It turns out that if they went completely
blind before around the age of 5-7 years old,
they will typically dream without any visual
experiences.
In the very few cases where some report having
visual experiences in their dreams, these
experiences are more in the abstract sense
where they feel like they were seeing something,
even though they couldn’t actually recollect
or describe when they woke up what the thing
looked liked that they saw.
This is similar to how occasionally in dreams
you can just “know” something, even though
there is nothing specifically that you are
experiencing in the dream which should indicate
what you know.
For instance, in a dream where when you wake
up, you remember feeling like you were in
danger in the dream, even though nothing you
can recall in the dream indicated any danger.
There was just some abstract sense of it.
Outside of the interesting “around the age
of 5-7” cutoff for visual dream experiences,
the dreams of those who are completely blind
before this age tend to be principally auditory
in nature.
However, what is also fascinating is that,
compared to those who can see and hear, the
blind report drastically increased taste/smell/touch
sensations in their dreams, not just auditory
sensations taking over for the lack of visual
sensations.
Now if they go completely blind after around
the age of 5-7, the vast majority of completely
blind people will at first dream very similar
dreams to those who are not blind, albeit,
once again, with more non-visual sensory experiences
than is reported by those who can see and
hear.
But nevertheless, their visual experiences
in their dreams tend to be quite similar to
those who can see.
If they had diminished vision early on in
life though, perhaps only seeing colors, then
their visual experiences in their dreams tend
to be similarly diminished based on those
visual experiences.
As time passes, they typically will report
more and more prevalence of experiences from
the other senses and less and less visual
experiences in dreams.
Often the visual experiences will become more
vague and “blurry” as time passes, but
they do seem to remain to some extent throughout
the blind person’s entire life.